[Music]
jennifer is in houston hi jennifer
welcome to the ramsey show
hi uh thank you so much for having me my
pleasure quick question uh we are on
baby step uh four six and seven um we
completed baby step three then my
husband and i have a difference of what
that looks like so would we save three
to six months worth closer to three or
six
and does that if we like say if i lose
my job today right i'm not going to go
get my nails and hair done so like down
to the bare minimum
or what actual six month spending looks
like
uh probably between these two at your
stage
uh and you can pick the three or the
sixth month that's not the issue but
then is it absolute bare bones or does
it mean no uh
uh
known there no no hair no nails all that
kind of stuff so um uh uh what's your
household income
uh about 160 yeah
and um
how old are your two cars
uh how old i just bought a car for cash
of 2014 lexus and he has a uh
14 exhibition okay you got two good cars
yeah you're not you're not dying on cars
so here's the thing that i discovered
and the reason i'm asking these things
when you're broke and you're just
getting started you remember those years
back in the day
everything's a freaking emergency
because you're broke
right
and you're driving junk cars
and you know you haven't done all the
maintenance on the house so even more
stuff's breaking
and so it's like you're in the fact that
you're broke is inviting more strain
on the emergency fund later on when
you've got more money and the air
conditioner is getting serviced
regularly on the house and as soon as
there's one little thing on the roof you
fix it immediately it doesn't leak and
create a bigger mess and it's and you're
driving decent cars so they're not
breaking down and you don't wait until
there's a flat tire you happen to notice
when they're going getting a little bare
and you go change them out early where
when you're broke you have to drive them
until they blow you know
and so what happens is you get more
margin in all these areas of your life
so the weird thing is is the more money
you get the less need of an emergency
fund you have
because there's fewer emergencies is
that logical
yeah absolutely and we have a 2 15 year
old and a four year old and then the
only other factor would be that um i'm
wondering if we should pile it up a
little more i hate my job i've been
looking at ken coleman's stuff
and my performance has not been where it
should be just because i'm i'm just
making myself get up and go to work
every day um should we add a little more
to it that's not an emergency
okay that's a transition
if you want to set some money to the
side for job transition you can do that
feel free okay feel free set you 10 or
15 20 grand over there for job
transition but let's not confuse that
with the emergency fund
the emergency funds for emergencies this
is not an emergency this is a problem we
need to fix
right christmas is not an emergency it's
always in december it's predictable
it's predictable that two years from
today you're not gonna be working at
that place
god i hope not
and jennifer listen
can i can i you didn't even ask this can
i push on you for a second
please do
please
don't sacrifice your dignity and your
respectability in your work ethic
and say things like my job performance
is slipping just because i don't feel
like going anymore
if you're still employed they're still
taking their money show up and give a
thousand percent and then when you're
looking for jobs give a thousand percent
on your job transition
but you will it will keep you from
walking six inches lower right with your
head health you will walk with your head
held high your chin held up you will
clean out your desk when you get that
new job with a smile on your face yeah
don't
you're not a person that mails it in no
that's not who you are
yeah so but yeah go ahead and make the
transition and set some money aside for
that and if you want to
what's happening is is that transition
is scaring you and that's what's making
you want to put the emergency fund on up
and so put 25 000 over there right quick
in the next few months to make this
transition that's not that's a
transition fund it's not an emergency
fund and then you then you won't be
worried about your emergency fund
anymore because your emergency fund
probably just fine i love that idea dave
so that's you would a transition a new
baby coming you need to get a new car
none of those are emergencies those are
just we need to have a sinking fund that
we create and save up for that yeah you
know what the problem is and it's not
her situation but it's just to all of us
in america we were just taught to have a
savings account that's it that's exactly
right one and you know what a savings
account is it's a put and take account
you put money in there you take it out
put money in there take it out and buy a
bass boat put money in there fix air
conditioner put money in there put
stitches in the kid's head put money in
there it's a put and take put and take
put and take and so it's all this stuff
is combined in this one general account
that that you always watch it and it
just never seems to do what it's
supposed to do because no one knows what
it's really supposed to do it's never
enough or look at all that money i got
right yeah and when you separate out
your savings and you say every savings
dollar has to have a job a mission an
assignment okay this is you this one's
job is transition
this one's job is christmas this one's
job is car replacement and this one's
job is emergencies and don't confuse
them i love that buying a bass boat is
not an emergency there is no situation
ever on planet earth in which you can
describe a bass boat purchase as an
emergency it's not on the list i i can
emotionally get there but intellectually
we're all laughing right now right and
so you know that that's i was forced to
buy a new car no you aren't they didn't
have a gun
you chose to buy a new car and so these
are the things but that's the reason is
it and it helped me a ton
uh because my nature's not a i'm not
naturally a saver it helped me a ton to
say these things have a goal because i
am goal oriented and once i have
something with a goal then ding ding
ding i can do it i love i'm writing that
down every
savings dollar has a job too
different than your light bill or your
food or what
every every dollar you are saving has a
job as well it's a little bit of the
frustration of when you're investing
just in general
and what do we do we call it we're
saving for retirement yeah what does
that even mean what does retirement even
mean and uh
you know
we started saying a few years ago around
here you know retirement's not a number
it's not a number it's a it's a it's a
it's not it's not a destination it's not
a thing so all we're really saying is we
want to build some wealth
but when you don't even have that you
know it's just very vague it's like i
just want a big pile of money yeah
there's it's not motivating nope but if
you say you know i want to build a
hospital for children
and that's going to cost
40 million dollars i mean 40 million
dollars now you got something you're
aiming at i can go get it yeah then you
can go get it you got a reason for doing
this it changes everything
very cool stuff